[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 30 septembre le
début d'une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 60,18
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez voici
les titres de ce journal après la
disparition de jacques chirac la journée
de deuil national et d'obsèques ce lundi
des minutes de silence ont été observées
dans les mairies yvelinois cet après
midi et une cérémonie d'hommage est
également prévue ce soir à 19h à poissy
saint cyr l'école relève le défi m'a
cité va briller une cinquantaine de
personnes dont de nombreux jeunes à
participer au nettoyage du quartier
gérard philipe samedi ce challenge
partie du val d'oise fin juillet a fait
le tour de france et puis c'est le
premier de la saison toute cette semaine
la rédaction consacre un dossier au
cinéma dans le département focus ce soir
sur les jeunes qui se forment aux
métiers du secteur à l'école troisième à
elancourt et ils vont m'accompagner
pendant une grande partie de cette
édition joséphine coleman berger bonsoir
mr va les républicains de plaisir
bonsoir ses fans en sont parfois
professeur de droit public à la faculté
de droit et de science politique de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines avec vous on s'interrogera est
notamment de la trace que l'ess jacques
chirac dans l'histoire de la politique
française
[Musique]
elle le deuil national trois jours après
la disparition de jacques chirac les
obsèques de l'ancien président de la
république se sont tenues aujourd'hui à
paris cérémonie privée aux invalides
puis une messe en l'église saint-sulpice
suivi par plusieurs milliers de
personnes
un moment de recueillement aussi dans
les écoles et à la préfecture des
yvelines à versailles ou à près de 200
personnes ont assisté à une minute de
silence
à 15 heures on va peut-être voir les
images personnel de la préfecture du
conseil départemental est mais aussi des
anonymes étaient présents l'hymne
national ja et antonin vous n'avez pas
vu ces images vous allez peut-être voir
ces images attrape ou une minute de
silence a été également observée à 15
heures comme dans plusieurs dans toutes
les communes yvelinoise le maire divers
gauche guy malandain qui a côtoyé
jacques chirac lorsque celui ci était
premier ministre puis président a tenu à
faire un discours en amont l'élu a mis
en avant un chef d'état le chef d'état
au même niveau que deux autres
dirigeants français le général de gaulle
et françois mitterrand il retient de
jacques chirac son engagement dans les
valeurs républicaines écouter guy
malandain au micro de de mélanie poker
je suis comme ça parce que quand j'étais
premier multi jets dû voter contre 80%
de ce qu'ils présentaient mais je veux
dire que le c'était du vrai débat
c'était du vrai débat politique un homme
qui faisait la tension jeu s'ils
allaient tout à l'heure j'ai rapporté
cinq lois quelques unes sous son mandat
en eau peu et puis d'autres en
opposition et cetera jamais jamais il
est passé à côté de maçon
bonjour comme il le disait aux autres
parlementaires qui étaient là hommage
également que nous avons suivi à
montigny le bretonneux ou la première
maire-adjointe à faire un rapide
discours excusant l'absence du maire et
d'autres adjoints discours suivi d'une
minute de silence puis
d'applaudissements des élus employés de
mairie et unis montrent un présent
jacques chirac qui avait tenu un meeting
au stade pierre de coubertin pour sa
campagne de 1995 et qui était venue
inaugurer aussi est la ferme du manet en
1991 suzanne blanc alors élu municipal
et responsable de la circonscription rpr
se souvient au micro de marie line yapi
chez nous à ce moment là j'ai été
présenté officiellement à jacques chirac
par étienne panne qui était notre député
du moment comme étant la responsable de
son parti
balla et donc c'est un très grand moment
que j'ai vécu avec bonheur comme j'en ai
vécu énormément puisque dès 1984 aux 83
avec mon mari nous avons fait toutes les
campagnes de jacques chirac
mais joséphine coleman ce berger hommage
également dans votre commune à plaisir
où les drapeaux aussi sont en berne
depuis la fin de semaine dernière vous
avez mis aussi à la disposition des
habitants en mairie un registre pour
voilà écrire un mot aux mémoires de
jacques chirac pourquoi c'est important
pour vous de faire participer la
population à ce moment de recueillement
mais je pense que cet élan a été
nationale on l'a bien senti
c'était un élan qui n'avait rien de
politique c'était très humain c'était
affectueux
donc il me semblait tout à fait je
dirais important de pouvoir répondre à
des demandes qui ont été faites dans la
notre municipalité à la mairie pour
pouvoir laisser un petit quelque chose
pour la famille et donc la rosa on a
souhaité aux les accompagner comme ça on
va rester avec nous il est venu nous
parler de la semaine de l'environnement
qui a débuté à plaisir c'est la deuxième
pour la ville plaisir ou à onze on va en
parler pardon tout à l'heure on me dit à
l'oreillette qu'on devait donc on doit
avoir karl olive aux siens dans ce
journal ou une cérémonie car le livre le
maire de poissy où une cérémonie doit se
tenir à 19h car le livre qui n'est pas
encore avec nous en
direct on le retrouvera peut-être tout à
l'heure dans ce journal je me tourne
vers vous stéphane minson professeur de
droit public à lui fait est ce qu avec
donc ses nombreuses hommage qu'on a pu
voir aujourd'hui en france dans les
yvelines des milliers de personnes qui
ont fait aussi là que ce week-end ce
dimanche pour se recueillir devant le
cercueil de jacques chirac jusqu'à aussi
très tôt ce matin comment on explique
qu'un président de la république qui a
pu clivé politiquement bénéficie d'un
tel un tel hommage d'une telle
popularité
je n'oserais pas vous dire que les
français aiment bien leur président une
fois qu'ils sont décédés mais pas loin
il faut pas oublier que comme les autres
que jacques chirac sommes tous j'allais
dire les grandes figures qui ont marqué
la vie politique de notre pays
jacques chirac a connu des moments de
très grande impopularité extrêmement
violent extrêmement nombreuses
casseroles aussi politiques des
ministères des phrases voyez j'ai eu
l'honneur
bon c'est comme ça qu'il a aimé ça
commencer l'élu l'a dit lui même que
c'était un dérapage a plus que
malheureux bon et puis la suite a montré
qu' il n'était pas ce facho qu'il a été
décrit de manière assez rené pendant un
temps il ya enfin j'oserais vous dire là
aussi que jacques chirac c'est de ce
point de vue là de mon point de vue là
enfin le dernier président du xxème
siècle c'est-à-dire une longévité en
politique 40 ans on a lu et entendu
ces derniers jours que ça ne serait plus
possible je crois que c'est plutôt ce
que c'est plutôt bien avec les affaires
de cumul de mandats et cetera mais ça va
être compliqué maintenant pour pour des
grands élus de survivre pendant quarante
années qui est colossal ce qui est
énorme et puis une certaine manière
d'aborder la politique avec un appareil
politique derrière lui un parti
politique qu'il avait fondé le rpr en 76
pour lui permettre d'accéder à la
présidence une véritable machine
politique à son service tout ça
aujourd'hui c'est la politique d'hier
alors si la politique d'aujourd'hui
emprunte parfois assez largement y
compris dans une des aspects un peu un
peu négatif mais en tout cas cette
popularité je crois qu'elle est elle est
due à plusieurs facteurs d'abord au fait
que après avoir travaillé lui même
chirac a été trahi par balladur il est
entré dans la campagne présidentielle
vous savez avec avec ses poignard planté
dans le dos tel qu'on leur présentait
dans les guignols qui était une émission
extrêmement regarder à l'époque
et puis il ya eu aussi après après son
second mandat
un homme malade un homme affaibli que
les français ont pu au pouvoir et puis
il ya au delà de tout ça une
personnalité exceptionnellement
attachante
plus encore que les présidents il
l'avait précédé et plus encore me
semble-t-il que ceux qui lui ont succédé
alors il a été prise dans la république
de 1995 à 2007 plusieurs faits marquants
entre les deux mandats le duel au
deuxième tour des présidentielles de
2002 contre jean marie le pen son
discours sur le vel d'hiv son refus
aussi de s'engager en irak est ce qu'il
ya un moment où vous que vous retenez
dans ses deux mandats de président de la
république se mange heureux alors s'il
fallait retenir une chose et qui résonne
beaucoup à mon avis aujourd'hui c'est
son refus catégorique systématique de
s'allier avec les extrêmes et notamment
avec le front national
il a tenu bon et son dernier message
adressé aux français adressé à la nation
a été de dire en substance
méfiez-vous les extrêmes parce que les
extrêmes ça divise et puis ça m'a rien
de bon donc je pense que je retiens ce
côté un peu
il a dit aussi un peu radical socialiste
il était de mon point de vue plus
radical socialiste troisième république
que gaulliste et c'est un compliment du
malandain qui est un maire de gauche
maire de trappes le placer tout à
l'heure où au même niveau dans
l'histoire de la politique française que
le général de gaulle où françois
mitterrand est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce point de vue ça c'est très
subjectif il ya une affaire de longévité
que n'ont pas eu jusqu'à présent les
autres les autres chefs de l'état de la
vème république il ya une affaire de
personnalité et de style pourquoi pas
message allez-vous dire jacques chirac
entre dans l'histoire
mais il faudrait une histoire un peu
plus longue pour le pour le déterminer
et puis tout cela est extrêmement
personnel extrêmement subjectif merci à
stéphane mention pour cette analyse je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
droit public à l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines direction tout
de suite poissy où un hommage
républicain je le disais à tout à
l'heure
doit se tenir à 19h sur le parvis de la
mairie bonsoir karl olive france par
grégory bonsoir à tous vous êtes le
maire divers droite de poissy alors dès
l'annoncé jeudi de la mort de jacques
chirac vous avez décidé d'organiser
cette cérémonie il a eu des minutes de
silence
aujourd'hui pourquoi pourquoi ci est
organisée aussi cette cérémonie de ce
soir parce que jacques chirac ait été un
président dirait historique à président
de tous les français
un président gaulliste et il se trouve
que tout le monde se reconnaît
aujourd'hui dans dans l'image dans
l'héritage que nous laisse jacques
chirac savait jacques chirac aujourd'hui
s'il y avait un héritage en tout cas que
que les maires de terrain et joséphine
coltman berger en sait quelque chose
notre collègue maire de plaisir
cet héritage c'est d'être sur le terrain
d'être dans la proximité on voit bien
que jacques chirac adoré cela il le
disait il aimait les gens jacques chirac
et je le dis souvent aimé les gens ça
s'apprend pas dans le dictionnaire
donc ce soir on est content de partager
l'émotion inter-générationnelle je dis
bien intergénérationnel il ya beaucoup
de jeunes qui n'étaient pas nés au
moment même où chirac jacques chirac a
été élu président la république qui se
retrouve aujourd'hui parce que
finalement jacques chirac c'est un
président sympa jacques chirac il a
manqué à la politique et on s'aperçoit
depuis son décès qu'il manque aux
français alors vous parler d'héritage
votre engagement à vous politiquement
politique est assez récent une dizaine
d'années seulement est ce que jacques
chirac vous a marqué politiquement est
ce qui vous a donné aussi envie
peut-être de vous engager dans la
politique vous savez quand vous êtes
petit enfant arrière petit enfant de
résistants et que vous avez suivi à un
héritage gaulliste évidemment que
jacques chirac et le gaullisme parle et
aujourd'hui il ya une très belle
modernité dans ce que disait jacques
chirac
d'abord il y avait cette autorité un
chef est là pour chez fait c'est une
expression de jacques chirac
et puis derrière il y avait aussi cette
empathie au niveau des gens il aimait
les gens quels qu'ils soient de gauche
comme de droite d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
qui sera dire véritablement si jacques
chirac est un homme de gauche ou de
droite
c'était un président de la république de
toute la république sans ambages sans
ambiguïté à ce titre là lorsque vous
êtes maire vous ne vous levez pas le
matin en se demandant si vous allez
faire une politique de gauche ou une
politique de droite c'est ça aussi
l'héritage de la chiraquie merci karl
olive maire de poissy poissy où se tient
ce soir un hommage républicain c'est à
19h sur le parvis de l'hôtel de ville
[Musique]
politique toujours au niveau local en
fin de semaine dernière le conseil
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines se réunissait
pour la première fois en cette rentrée
une séance marquée par quelques
modifications dans les vice-présidences
après plusieurs démissions au sein et
des conseils municipaux ont fait le
point avec mélanie poker un conseil
d'agglomération plutôt calme en cette
fin de mois de septembre saint quentin
en yvelines reprenait le chemin des
délibérations au moment où plusieurs
conseils municipaux ont été chamboulées
on n'est pas inquiet vous avez sorti
d'ailleurs ce soit et même eu un petit
complément financier qu'on a donnée
parce que on avait de bons résultats
sans soldes choses n'ont pour l'instant
ça se passe plutôt bien
à cinq mois des élections municipales le
conseil d'agglomération voit une
nouvelle vice-présidente être nommé
daniel vialla élus à guyancourt récupère
le poste laissé vacant par
marie-christine le tarnec est
démissionnaire ce schéma
il était apprécié de tout le monde aussi
bien les maires de gauche que les maires
de droit que donc je pense qu'on va pas
changer quelque chose qui fonctionne
ils ont en plus des frais délégation
l'équipe de guyancourt
voilà je joue le jeu tentant on a on a
une différence sur un dossier etc
mais on en parle et on construit
ensemble c'est ça se finit toujours sur
une issue positive
parmi les délibérations un plan de
déploiement du numérique scolaires
inscrits dans le contrat yvelines
territoire du département d'un montant
de 7 millions d'euros
saint-quentin-en-yvelines y investira
plus d'un million cinq joséphine coleman
ce père j'étais toujours avec moi en
plateau justement au vice présidente de
saint quentin en yvelines est aussi
maire de plaisir dans votre ville où est
organisée la deuxième semaine de
l'environnement c'est jusqu'à dimanche
avec plusieurs animations au programme
pourquoi proposer cette semaine à vos
habitants écoutez ça fait plusieurs
années que nous sommes en réflexion
justement pour dynamiser autour de
l'environnement et toute cette
problématique qu'aujourd'hui nous vivons
par rapport à la planète comme on dit
c'est un petit peu généraliste mais il
est vrai que c'est un vrai sentiment que
qui est ressenti par la population
donc cette année on a encore forcé
davantage toutes les activités ce qu'on
avait déjà commencé les années
précédentes comme je me disais mais
cette année on a toute une semaine très
dense avec avec du nettoyage entendait
justement que ma collègue de saint cyr
l'école avait aussi déclenché quelque
chose mais il est vrai que nous on a mis
ça aussi samedi avec des enfants sur sur
toute la collectivité
on a aussi des activités avec des
soirées conférences on a aussi le répare
café on a une production théâtrale
exactement dans toute une série
d'activités qui je dirais doivent
sensibiliser s'est pas uniquement faire
quelque chose pour faire quelque chose
c'est véritablement quelque chose qui
doit sensibiliser au niveau
intergénérationnel puisque là on touche
aussi bien les enfants que les personnes
d'un certain âge et est important de que
tout le monde prenne conscience que la
pile de plaisir est véritablement
engagés dans cette démarche de
l'environnement et vous l'évoquiez les
habitants sont de plus en plus demandeur
ils sont plus en plus sensibilisés à ces
thématiques
alors non seulement ils sont demandeurs
mais il
il apporte aussi des idées l'apport des
actions justement pour aller dans ce
sens là puisque nous avons une
association qui s'appelle plaisir en
transition qui nous apporte
régulièrement toute une série
d'activités à mettre en place et avec la
ville on est partenaire pour pouvoir
développer tout ça je reconnais que
aujourd'hui il faut et je pas faire de
lien avec le livre
mais il parlait de génération terrain
dans le sens du maire terrain
aujourd'hui faut écouter les personnes
qui sont sur le territoire et toutes les
attentes que nous mettrons peu de clics
que nous mettons en place c'est parce
que aussi nous les entendons nous devons
être bien sûr précurseur dans beaucoup
de domaines mais on les entend et on y
répond donc on a toute une série
d'actions bien sûr qu'ils sont des
actions typique avec ce que je vous
disais comme des conférences et toute
une série de de théâtre d'improvisation
sur ce sujet là mais aussi sur des
choses qui sont peut être moins visibles
dans un premier temps mais qui sont
aussi des bornes électriques qui sont
installés de les covoiturages qu'on est
en train de développer les pistes
cyclables puisqu'on a un champ
aujourd'hui d'action aussi mise en place
là dessus plus de 4 millions d'euros
doivent être investis sur la
collectivité pour les pc sous la main
c'est toute une démarche complète et est
vraiment forte qui pour nous est plus
qu'indispensable aujourd'hui une semaine
de l'environnement à plaisir aussi sur
vos réseaux sociaux sur youtube le
quatrième plaisir en vrac vous donne
quelques astuces contre le gaspillage
alimentaire regardé en moyenne un
français comme moi jette environ 30 kg
de nourriture chaque année soit un repas
par semaine à la poubelle
ça laisse réfléchir en france on compte
des millions de tonnes de nourriture
jetée chaque année et ça coûte cher tout
ça représente 16 milliards d'euros à la
poubelle aussi mon argent vous êtes
sérieux nous devons donc un extrait du
quatrième numéro de plaisir en vrac qui
est animée par thomas c'est une
chronique youtube sur la ville de
plaisir ceci intéressant d'utiliser les
réseaux sociaux pour sensibiliser la sur
cette thématique de l'environnement
oui je crois que ça correspond plus est
ce que les jeunes attendent aussi comme
communication parce que l'humour en fait
partie et puis en même temps fait passer
des messages c'est vrai que les chiffres
qui sont annoncés là peuvent paraître
important mais quand je vous dis 34
tonnes de déchets dans les cantines sur
la ville de plaisir pendant une année
c'est colossal et tout ça nous allons le
récupérer pour le m bien sûr aujourd'hui
au niveau d'un traitement qui va nous
permettre aussi dans la méthanisation et
bien peut-être d'alimenter des bus et
des voitures sur le territoire pour
pouvoir et bien récupérer tout cela mais
bien sûr en parallèle on forme les
enfants pour qu'ils comprennent qu'il ne
faut pas gâcher un dernier mot lui aussi
forcément un côté festif
ce samedi c'est la fête du miel c'est un
événement classique à plaisir et qui
rattachent et du cou à cette semaine de
l'environnement fête du miel qui met en
avant notamment les les abbés qui voit
là c'est pour protéger les abeilles qui
sont ô combien importantes pour la
biodiversité s'en lamente à l'appui ce
cantique siegfried a bel et bien l'homme
à disparaître
on a des agriculteurs aussi qu'elle
fonctionne bien au niveau de cette
démarche là haut niveau de plaisir des
fraises agriculteurs et puis bien sûr on
a notre association fétiche qui
aujourd'hui est sûre d'un territoire et
qui fait cette foire aux aux miels et
dans lesquels il ya aussi des
producteurs qui vient qui viennent
d'autres villes c'est un bon moment si
vous voulez goûter du miel et manger du
pain d'épicés extraordinaire fournir un
plaisir ce week le messager est lancé ce
même de l'environnement jusqu'à dimanche
à plaisir le programme complet bien sûr
à retrouver sur le site internet de la
ville merci joséphine coleman leur merci
à vous mr les républicains de plaisir
c'est un défi justement rapport avec
l'environnement qui a fait le tour de
france l'opération ma cité va briller a
investi saint-cyr-l'ecole une
cinquantaine de personnes dont plusieurs
enfants s'est mobilisée pour nettoyer le
quartier gérard philipe
initiative lancée localement par
plusieurs associations reportage de
nicolas landry est la voix de manon par
aldo sincère l'école veut faire briller
sa cité des nombreux jeunes du quartier
gérard philipe ont participé au
nettoyage de leur lieu de vie avec un
sac poubelle à la main des gants et la
volonté de protéger l'environnement ils
ont ramassé de nombreux déchets c'est
important parce que non vu que
l'environnement il reste intacte qu'il
n'y a pas de défauts qui a pas de
pollution
donc on est là on est dans soutient tout
ça c'est plutôt cool hein c'est arrêter
de polluer à respecter sa ville protéger
l'environnement c'est ne pas l'abîmer
cette opération nettoyage s'inscrit dans
le défi m'a cité va briller lancé par
des quartiers de garges les gonesse dans
le val d'oise à saint-cyr-l'ecole
l'association audace a lancé
l'initiative accompagnés par les
colibris
c'est important aspect positif en
général quand on parle de quartier 7 sur
des aspects un peu négatif
et là c'est une bonne chose que les
propres jeunes de leurs propres
quartiers prennent des initiatives pour
essayer d'améliorer leur quartier tout
simplement
l'association audace havre pour les
jeunes de ce quartier un accompagnement
sportif culturel et social connu par la
municipalité
c'est des jeunes que je connais un que
je vois tout au long de l'année et
aujourd'hui je contente de les voir se
sont mobilisés pour
pour un beau challenge et qu'est ce
qu'on en dit je pense qu'ils sont tous
complètement conscient après c'est
toujours pareil c'est le geste
individuel qui est compliqué c'est le
changement de mentalité et c'est la
tradition pour ma cité va briller le
quartier gérard philipe a lancé le défi
à une autre ville laissant syrien en
nommer fontenay-le-fleury 52 minutes
c'est en moyenne le temps de trajet
domicile travail pour les franciliens en
transport en commun pour permettre aux
sarlat au salarié et d'optimiser à ce
déplacement en temps de travail une
start-up saint-quentinoise a imaginé un
bus ultra-connectés une première
expérimentation à s'est déroulée entre
paris et le site airbus à elancourt
marylène iapichino patrick jacques de
dixmude et rodolphe blondel d'apparence
ordinaire ce bus le mobile office est en
réalité une pépite technologique à
l'intérieur ses utilisateurs peuvent se
connecter à leurs réseaux d'entreprise
et même réaliser des visioconférences
sans coupure de réseau
ce concept est équipé un bus de moyens
de télécommunications sécurisées pour
permettre un soin de faire une connexion
pendant tout le trajet mais aussi
d'avoir des connexions particulière vers
les réseaux de l'entreprise ont une
qualité de réseau assurée par airbus
pour un projet développé par son moving
une start-up saint-quentinoise missionné
de trouver des solutions pour attirer
les jeunes ingénieurs vers ces sites
extérieurs à paris sans perte de temps
c'est tout le propre de la première
expérimentation qu'on souhaiterait
lancer pour sur une période de six mois
en début d'année ce sera effectivement
de pouvoir valider et notamment avec
l'air les relations les ressources
humaines d des entreprises concernées
cette capacité qu'auraient les
collaborateurs à être considéré comme
sûr le lieu de travail
une première expérimentation qui
visitent également à séduire
ile-de-france mobilité pour envisager un
test à plus grande échelle voir une mise
en service réelle de ces bus à aux
moyens de communication les transports
du futur c'est bien sûr au centre
de saint quentin et en plus la
présidente de la région de france est
très centré à la raison ont porté sur le
télétravail sur les supports numériques
aujourd'hui permettent d'envisager que
le temps de transport en fait soit
quasiment dans le temps de travail
objectif mettre en place une ligne
régulière début 2020 pour réaliser tous
les tests et perfectionner le mobile
office aux ambitions de déploiement
international
chaque mois le dossier de la rédaction
de tv 78 toute cette semaine focus sur
le cinéma dans le département à
l'occasion des 50 ans du cnc les
archives du septième art qui sont
installés à bois d'arcy pour ce premier
numéro focus sur l'école qui forme les
futurs cinéastes à les installer à
elancourt c'est l'école troisième focus
avec mathilde et demi
dans la salle de montage il aime se
concentre sur son projet en cours
il apprend ce matin à monter plusieurs
images sur son logiciel lent mais sûr
d'une caméra c'est c'est un nouveau truc
on en apprendra fait pour un mini mac je
pense ce sera surtout un projet pour un
prochain projet là qu'on a dans pas
longtemps dans quelques semaines comme
lui 1300 étudiants décidé de devenir
monteur réalisateur scénariste cameraman
ou encore son dié au campus 3 yes
plusieurs formations sont proposées aux
étudiants pour être opérationnels à la
sortie de l'école on reste attaché à
l'idée que le cinéma ont pour la prendre
il faut le faire tout simplement
donc pour faire du cinéma il faut avoir
les moyens techniques il faut avoir les
locaux il faut avoir des intervenants de
qualité il faut avoir vraiment un site
et des équipements dédiés à
l'enseignement du cinéma et
l'audiovisuel au sens large
donc nous
à 50 ans ni ville on a deux bâtiments on
a plus de 14 mille mètres carrés de
surface d'équipements dédiés et on fait
vraiment sorte dans notre pédagogie
au delà des enseignements théoriques de
la culture artistique des enseignements
pratiques nous notre notre démarche
c'est vraiment la mise en situation
professionnelle la création la technique
et la polyvalence sont les qualités les
plus importantes pour eric d'un kg en
référent de la tuillière réalisation et
fiction pour s'adapter au mieux au monde
du travail mais aussi pour se démarquer
de ce milieu très sélectif quand on suit
une formation de réalisation fiction à
l'école on apprend à concevoir un court
métrage particulièrement mais aussi
d'autres aspects de la fiction comme des
séries c'est à dire qu'on apprend à
superviser des équipes donc que l'on
soit l'origine ou non donc du projet on
chapote l'écriture et puis après la
constitution d'une équipe et toutes les
étapes de production jusqu'à la
finalisation du film donc on apprend à
diriger à concevoir et on apprend
surtout bas à employer ses moyens comme
une force et non pas comme une limite
apprendre à travailler en groupe est une
notion importante dans le cinéma car
pour créer un court métrage il faut de
nombreux intervenants pour avoir un
résultat final benjamin l'a bien compris
et prépare déjà son prochain projet avec
les autres filières
mais en ce moment on est en train de
travailler avec d'autres filières dont
la production
le montage le son l'image l'assistanat
réa et les journalistes
le but c'est de ramener toutes les
filières et de les mettre ensemble pour
qu'on fasse une émission donc sur
plusieurs thématiques à la fin des trois
années d'études à trois aces 87% des
étudiants trouvent un travail
une école qui se développe grâce à ses
nombreuses formations et à ses campus
pour permettre aux étudiants des outils
d'apprentissage de qualité souvenirs
avant de refermer ce journal il ya tout
juste un an se clôturait la ryder cup
2018 au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines trois jours de
compétition entre les meilleurs golfeurs
mondiaux qui avait vu la team europe
sacré pour la douzième fois face aux
états unis de tiger woods vous voyez à
francesco molinari à l'écran à l'italien
qui avait inscrit le point de la
victoire l'événement avait attiré plus
de 250 mille spectateurs sur place et
générer entre 21 et 24 millions d'euros
de retombées économiques pour
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise toutes
les actualités sportives à retrouver
d'ailleurs dans un instant l'émission
cetud sport et retour à la présentation
de à michael et demi d'euros voilà c'est
la fin du set 8 journal merci de l'avoir
suivi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver dès demain pour une nouvelle
édition belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]